it's one day to go has election fever
gripped the nation do you think well I
think so I mean sudden suddenly been
gripping people like me for a long time
now and but the interesting thing is
that while the campaign's been going on
for at least six weeks now you could
argue the polls haven't actually shifted
very much if we take them as a group
then things are really quite similar to
how they were last month when both
parties were as it as they are now
getting around thirty-three thirty-four
percent of the vote so take them as a
group things seem very tight between
labor and the Tories the only note of
caution our dad is that we're not
certain that things are tied the Tories
maybe a few more points ahead than we
think that's what some phone poles are
suggesting so it's an unclear pictures
yet can we trust the polls Harry well I
think we can but I think the important
point is if you look back at 2010 the
polls weren't exactly right they
overestimated the lib dem vote they
thought the Clegg mania would have more
of an effect than it did so the polls
are often quite quite good but slightly
wrong I mean they got the Tory boat very
accurate last time and if we go further
back 97 or 2001-2005 the polls are by
and large quite accurate but obviously
in 1992 famously they were very
inaccurate so in some can we trust them
what I think they'll they'll be quite
well but something will be slightly
wrong this time when buta who do they
speak to I mean how many people on each
disease poll on average actually speak
to their quite small sample something
they are but the amazing thing about
poses what we do is you talked about a
thousand people and the mass works such
that if you talk to a thousand people
then 19 times out of 20 the people you
talk to will represent the whole
population all 63 million of us within
three percent of accuracy so if a poll
says that the Torah John thirty five
percent that really means there are
anywhere from 30 to two thirty-eight
percent which doesn't seem that precise
but but we have quite a lot of polls
saying very similar things which gives
us quite a lot of confidence Sky News
poll of polls at the polls do suggest a
hung parliament in your mind is that
inevitable
that's certainly inevitable the question
really is both who has the largest
number of seats although we are fairly
certain that's going to be the Tories
and the crucial question becomes who can
cobble together a coalition and get to
the magic number of 323 seats the really
interesting thing is that while David
Cameron may win the most votes and even
may win the most seats ed Miliband
probably has the most likely path to 323
the problem is Harry with all these
poles there are still large numbers
undecided some say as many as a third of
voters is there not a chance in the next
24 hours a third of voters could decide
to go one way I could decide to go the
other and we could actually have an
outright winner on Friday it's possible
but it's unlikely everything we know
about the way undecideds eventually vote
is that they don't tend to shift in one
great bulk to one part or the other they
tend to buy large go the same way as
decided to go it's very unlikely that
we'll see such a big shift at the end of
the day but there is one load of caution
in Israel a few months ago Benjamin
Netanyahu was reelected after squeezing
a right wing votes and winning slightly
more than the polls expected him to vote
had to win and there is a possibility
that David Cameron picks up a few you
Clippers in the next 24 hours and does
slightly better than we expect
interesting stuff Harry I'm sure we'll
be speaking to you again over the next
48 hours thanks very much